Please welcome Molly Bernard.
Molly!
(audience cheering)
Hi Molly.
Hi, I'm freaking out.
How are you doing?
I am so good.
How are you?
I'm good.
This is like a weird dream though, right?
We're sitting here, Drew's getting a tattoo, Molly's here.
I know this is so fun.
I mean, Molly we were so excited to do the news with you
because you know, your show like really
shows the power of friendship.
And I know that you've become so close
with Hillary Duff over the years and the thing that
other than my daughters has meant the most
to me in my life is my friendships.
Same.
Tell me about your relationship
with Hillary and your history and your future.
You know, I had just graduated
from the Yale School of Drama, when I got on this show.
I had no idea what I was doing and I was so stressed out
and wanted to make sure everything was perfect.
And one day on set, she was like, "Just chill.
You're funny and like, we love you just be a little
be a little less stressed out
'cause it's kind of stressful",
and that kind of realness, she-
Good advice, right?
It's really good advice.
And I carry it on every set I go to,
I carry it into my work and that should
we just kind of became fast friends because she saw
through my BS and she was like, you don't need it actually.
You'll be lighter without it,
and that carries through, into our friendship.
I mean, she's the best friend I have.
Would you mind doing a couple of news stories with us?
I can't wait to do news stories.
Okay, good.
Drew, just checking in on Drew,
how you feeling over there?
I just got reminded not to move.
Okay, understood.
(laughing)
All right.
Well, Molly, our first story is
about someone near and dear to your heart.
Mae, Hillary Duff's one month old baby.
You'll look at this Yahoo!life reports
that Hillary brought Mae to meet Mandy Moore's newborn, Gus
and they had a blast.
And I know that you and Hillary of course your besties
from younger.
And, but there's an interesting story,
you went to go help with baby Mae
and ended up staying for what?
Like?
A month.
A month, you went to go, what is that like?
She just needed your help and you were there?
Actually, we weren't sure when she was going to be born,
Mae not Hillary, we knew that.
And I, so I planned to go out to LA for vaguely a month
and to see when the baby came and I mean this is her third,
so I really wanted to be an extra set of hands.
Yeah.
And I'm her other daughter's godmother.
So I was just, I mean, I got to do bath time
and bed time and then wake up time is the best.
They're so tender in the mornings,
when they wake up, come on.
How did it feel to hold that little tiny baby?
She is edible.
And she was so, so, so, so, so cuddly too.
She loved to be held.
And Banks, Banks was like that too.
Really?
Hillary makes really cuddly people.
Ooh.
And I feel like I'm so lucky,
I'm like a parent and training.
She's taught me and my partner, Hannah, how to be,
she's such a good mother.
May I ask?
Because I was so scared with Olive,
and then I a bit calmer with Frankie.
What is Hillary like with her second and third,
is she different?
Is she, you know what she like as a mom?
I hope she doesn't get mad at me for saying this,
but she,
you know how parents buy the one month old, two month old?
Like the, the blankets that you put the baby on
and take pictures of, she didn't have one for Mae,
and so she got one for the day after Mae turned a month old,
she was like, "It's a third kid thing."
(laughing)
Just at that point you're like, right?
I'd love for you to read the next story, Molly.
Because I think that I really wanna hear
from you and Ross, what you guys think of this?
All right, here we go.
Okay.
Next up, I'm planning my wedding right now.
Yes.
And Ross, I know you are too!
Yes, we're both in recently engaged.
Recently queer engaged, thank dog herself.
So I want to take on this new wedding trend.
Okay.
All right.
It is the Who What Wear reports second looks
are becoming a thing for bridesmaids.
And this basically means that your bridesmaids
will wear the matchy-matchy look to the ceremony
but then at the reception,
they can change into whatever they want.
Yes.
What do we think?
I love this idea because weddings are so formal,
and I hate the idea of people coming together
and being uncomfortable all day long.
Like sure, show up in heels,
But then when it's time for the reception
can we all just agree to be in elastic?
Is that all right?
Yes.
Absolutely no buttons.
No buttons.
I just unzipped the zipper from my skirt
'cause Ryan told me she wanted me relaxed.
So I was like, then I need to unzip.
(laughing)
Before we go Molly,
I would love for you to tell us about your new film,
"Milkwater".
I think the storyline is beautiful, significant
and I'm really excited that it's becoming more of a common,
acceptable, beautiful conversation out in the world.
Will you please tell us about it?
I would love to.
I made this film, it's the first film that I'm leading,
which is really exciting.
And it's about how difficult it is to start queer families.
I play a really lost millennial who befriends
an older gay man at a drag bar.
And-
I can't relate.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I'm sure
you can't relate, yeah.
You don't know anything about this.
So she befriends this drag queen and offers to be
his surrogate kind of the night that she meets him.
And it explores boundaries and boundarilessness
and just how vulnerable it is to rely on a surrogate
for starting your family.
And my, you know, my partner and I are about
to go on the marriage journey and the kid's journey.
And it's, it's hard when you're two women or two men and,
or when you're as this film depicts a single gay man.
Surrogacy, I think is a very important conversation.
Do you guys wanna have kids?
We do!
I mean, honestly, I think Hannah and I were like
cause playing at Hillary's house, I'd be like,
"You run the bath, I'll go take her,
I'll get her, you know, I'll some of the clothes off
make sure the bubbles are in, make sure it's not too hot."
And Hannah would be like, "Got it, you look hot."
And I was like, "Yes".
We like had so much fun.
Well, thank you, Molly.
I am so honored that you came to the desk today.
It was so nice to talk about family, friendship, surrogacy,
you know, life, really what a-
The real stuff.
What a menu and "Milkwater" is on demand on May 21st.
(upbeat music)